I had a vision I had Maury Fame glory
good luck sorry all everything that man
will ever want to look I still I had
everything but yet it did mean nothing I
wanted to die on a daily basis many
people they make these these assumptions
and they connect weird things to
religion at this point I'd never I've
never begged or cried to God to help me
before I prayed a lot all my life but
I've never been in this physical state
before like I feel tears running down my
face apiece how are you doing how you
doing we got an exciting episode for you
as always hamdulillah subscribe if you
haven't already hit the notification
bell to get a new and exciting I was so
sent to you on a regular basis my good
friends in the studio dr. Lawrence Brown
Salaam alaikum
how are you how you been good good good
it's good to have you back on the
program good to be back good to be back
in Chicago I'm gonna let this video play
off and then we're gonna go ahead and
react to this how did you realize that
you had mental health issues I mean I
what was it exactly was I got anxiety
PTSD yeah yeah anxiety started to come
heavily and I always suffered with
depression I was on top of the world it
became more and more and more depressed
until it was like suicidal thoughts and
Maury Fame glory
good luck sorry all everything that man
will ever want to look I still I had
everything but yet it did mean nothing I
wanted to die on a daily basis so
material goods are only good for when
things are going right in your life when
everything's rolling gold and
everything's happy then material goods
are okay but you can have everything in
the world and feel like [ __ ] on a daily
basis no one can see inside the mind for
those that aren't know my this is one of
the most talked-about individuals at the
moment because he's got a
fight coming up he's uh I believe he's
an undefeated heavyweight champion he he
won retired and then life just went you
know you would think now you you're the
heavyweight champion of the world
life is good not you could retire but
this is what happens uh you know I mean
I just think about how so many people
feel an emptiness in their lives and
that's whether you're rich or poor
whether you're unknown or famous
whatever your state in life is there
there are so many people who feel an
emptiness a hole that they just can't
fill and it's a spiritual void it's a
spiritual void and it cannot be filled
by materialism and you know we we hear
this over and over again what we just
saw and we see it on a daily basis
because almost everybody is in a store
on a daily basis and they're checking
out and they're seeing those you know
they're the celebrity magazines at the
checkout counter and there's always
somebody who's decompensating somebody
in a crisis somebody going through you
know something like this you know and
it's it's so predictable that it's
basically a cliche this is something
that if I'm going to read read to you
some the statistics you have some from
the from the CDC and others talking
about that suicide not only is it taking
the lives of someone every 12.3 minutes
not only is it continuing to increase on
a yearly basis it also is affecting kids
at a young age this is what staggering
it's the second leading cause of death
ten leading cause of death in the US but
second leading cause of death for the
age range between ten and thirty four
years old so every twelve point three
minutes someone in America is taking
their life
kids at the young age of between ten and
thirty four keeps climbing and climbing
and climbing and they say that according
to CDC fifty point 54% did not have
mental health issues so a lot of people
like he was stating it was going back to
mental so there is a place yet mental
health something that has to do with
with your current state of mind we're
covering we're talking more specifically
a void you just mentioned a void
avoiding the heart or so it's something
tangible but you can't touch that feel
that huh how do you would put all of
these things together to know which one
where and wait which way to go and how
to to deal with it you know basically to
answer that question I have to fall back
on my own personal experience and the
experience of others who have gotten
over this and that's you know just kind
of the universal solution is recognizing
that you you do not fill that void with
things of this world your you do not
achieve peace satisfaction contentment
until you are satisfied spiritually and
so I think it was I think it was loon
you know the rapper loon who basically
said that he got up to a point in his
life where he could he could have
everything except peace you know he had
everything except for peace and so you
know I went through this a lot of other
people have gone through this where they
think that having that the big house
they think that having the car they want
to think that it you know they keep
thinking about the material arrangements
in life but then when they get them it
satisfies them for a little while but
it's not lasting mm-hmm
and the easiest thing to do is also kind
of the hardest thing to do
yeah and that is turning turning to your
Creator and and seeking the religion of
truth seeking the truth of the creator
and doing so with a commitment to submit
you know but a lot of people have a real
hard time with that they don't want to
you know they're they're afraid of it
they're afraid it's gonna take them
places they don't want to go and so they
they just they just cannot but usually
you're in a place where you don't want
to be he didn't want to be here so if
people can imagine that because this is
the norm in our society from the kids to
the adults they look up to people like
this because he's got the radio he
meaning that he's on the radio shows the
television shows he's fighting on the
big screen life is good
so this is I like pointing pointing
these instances out so people can
actually see the reality so why am we
showing this because you see someone
like this he's at the top of his game
he's at the top of life he's at the
pinnacle and then what happens he's
young he's not even reached his 30s I
believe before his 30s he's done he's
he's accomplished his life his dream
he's got money he's got like he said I
had everything you can want and imagine
and then what does he tell us that he's
thinking about suicide constantly he's
depressed he's starting in a in a full
state of despair but now at the end they
talk about that okay this is so how do
you distribute mental health so what do
you I mean we're talking about a void in
a heart there's a spiritual void right
CDC is saying that 54 percent of people
who committed suicide
they had no signs or any any signals or
anything to do with mental health so how
do you like mental health verse do you
go towards dealing with like okay you go
to your doctor you get things in many of
these pills for people to get the pills
and they from the doctor they become
addicted right to the painkillers that
opens up a whole new world we're not
saying that someone should not of course
you go to your medical professional you
do all that but you're talking about
something that people like it's over the
head but it's the it's the it's the it's
it's the remedy for most of these ills I
mean I've got to fall back on what I
find in the Quran which is the solution
to me and it's just it's just clear you
get all religious now man
well look it's just where are you gonna
find
of your existence as a creation where
are you going to find the answers better
than what you find from the Creator you
always go back to the source and you
know in any in any research you always
go back to the source and the you know
the the source and the Islamic religion
is the Quran and the hadith of the
prophet sallallaahu Islam and the thing
about the Quran is yeah okay it's 1,400
years old but we know that it has not
been changed one letter since the time
of revelation and it's the only
scripture that bears that sanctity that
it's the only scripture that exists
which has been unchanged from the time
of Revelation so I mean that's it but
aside from aside from that I was just
going to say that if you're taking the
Quran as your book of guidance Allah
describes the things of this world is in
the translation of the meaning he
describes the things of this world as
chattels of deception and that's you
know and that that basically says all
these things are chattels of deception
they deceive us and we're deceived into
chasing after these things and we're
trading you know we're trading the you
know the better for the worse I mean we
could be we could be concentrating on
our spirituality we could be
concentrating on our relationship with
our Creator and instead we're focusing
on trying to get more money trying to
get more likes trying to get more
subscribers that that that that you know
well I'm not saying those things are not
satisfying or maybe even to some degree
important depending upon what your
objective is but I'm just I'm just
saying that to fill that void within you
to feel a sense of purpose to understand
your purpose in this life and to be
satisfied with your Creator and to not
have this depression to not be
despairing you get that from closeness
to your Creator you don't get it from
amassing material things to go off that
that's interesting because while Tyson
Fury where he describes going through
all of these traumatic instances and
almost at one point I don't know if he
was in his Lamborghini Ferrari one of
the fast cars almost hitting 200 miles
close to and that was it he was about to
run his car off to ditch the road and
kill himself then he heard some kind of
voice talking to him and kind of
persuading him you know not to do it and
then something else happened I'm gonna
show you and then we'll take off because
it kind of links to what you're saying
at this point I'd never I've never
begged or cried to God to help me before
I prayed a lot all my life but I've
never been in this physical state before
like a filled tears running down my face
my chest was wet with tears because I
knew I couldn't do it on my own it was
impossible for me cuz I tried and tried
and tried and ended up back in the pub
back drinking I almost accepted that
that was gonna be my fate an alcoholic
so I was on my knees in this bedroom
after praying for about 10 minutes I got
up and I felt the weight of the wall was
lifted off my shoulders and for the
first time in years I knew it was gonna
make a comeback so this is the turning
point now you're talking about the
Creator it seems like now a weight was
lifted off his shoulders where he
sincerely earnestly he's turning to God
what do you think about your what's your
action when you're here and talking
about this you know the thing is with
spiritual experiences like this I've had
them a lot of believers for had them and
a lot of non-believers have not had them
and unless you've had that experience
for yourself it's very hard to translate
I know what he's talking about I
understand what he's talking about I
felt it you've probably felt that a lot
of other believers have felt it but if
your audiences are disbelievers who are
just
saying I don't get it I don't believe it
it hasn't happened to me you know it's
very hard to translate that experience I
look at those experiences and I think
that those are personal experiences if
God means good for a person if Allah
intends good for a person he guides them
to Islam now you can believe that or not
but that's just simply the fact of the
matter and and so what I've noticed so
many times so many people with these
spiritual experiences it's their
awakening it's their epiphany it's their
turning point and and it sets them on
the path of discovery and you know that
that path you know frequently ends and
then becoming Muslim but it was a
private thing it was a it was a private
experience it's one you can't share any
more than you know when I tell the
spiritual experiences I've had two
people who do not have that spiritual
foundation I mean I can see the glaze
over their eyes the blankness on their
face they don't get it they don't get it
they just they don't have the mental /
spiritual context they don't have the
state of the heart that allows them to
understand the significance of that so I
look at it as a personal experience and
alhamdulillah hum did Allah he had it
and insha'Allah it will guide him to
good things but to try to translate that
to the broader audience out there you
have to have a special state of the
heart to be able to receive that and to
understand it for what it is and
understand it's real it's not a figment
of the imagination it's not it's not
something he's conjured up himself
pointing out these statistics and
showing examples like this and there and
there are so many it just repeated over
and over it's to connect with those
people who have kind of taken the new
they've made money materialism into a
God in and of itself pretty much and but
when you see for instance I don't know
what your take when you hear something
like the the statistics tell us that
established writers and artists like
celebrities are eighteen times get this
18 times more likely to commit suicide
so I believe that you know why is that
well you know being an author myself and
you know having having a written some
books which would classify as being
within the humanities meaning books of
entertainment not just purely books of
comparative religion when you are
working in the field of the humanities
you you are basically seeking the
appreciation of others and if you don't
get that or if it starts to go down like
these stars who were stars were a
listers and then you know they're you
know they're going down they're not
getting parts anymore they're not
getting you know invites engagements
roles whatever it's it's a bad feeling
and if that is your purpose okay if
that's you know if that's what you are
counting as your purpose in life right
people become despondent and many of
them just simply can't handle it mm-hmm
so that that's accurate
I often compared to the person that
keeps getting and other people who just
keep getting to the pinnacle of their
profession and they think that okay I'm
going to accomplish this I'm gonna get
Nobel Peace Prize or I'm gonna get this
noble reward or I'm gonna get the
Academy Award and I'm gonna be out there
in front of all these people and then
you still you get there and maybe you
have that moment of satisfaction but
what you were mentioning that void it's
still there then you go home and then
you're looking around and you just got a
check a paper with you know as Floyd
money Mayweather that he likes to flaunt
you've heard of him hundred million
dollar payday checks but then it's the
same anxieties and problems and it
doesn't necessarily go away but when he
he he did what he did this seemed to
have lifted he just sincerely he turned
to his creator but then where do you now
I he now he's got another he felt like
he came back
now from this he came back Tyson Fury he
said now I'm alive again and this is
what had him make a comeback but I'm
afraid what happens now I don't know if
you I mean only God Almighty knows the
future but you you make a foresight like
it's it's like we're just we're
creatures we keep sometimes repeating
the same mistake we learn a little bit
we pick up but then okay I'm right back
at it so I'm gonna get this championship
again make more money but still I did
turn to God but am i living truly how
the Creator wants me to live have I
truly turned my life to the crater have
I truly you know done with my Creator on
a daily basis is wanting me to do or
again you know I've used that moment
that he gave me a relief and I'm back at
it and then I put like the genie back in
the bottle when things are when things
are not going so good then I take you
know I use got you know that expression
you've heard where it's like you rub the
bottle the genie comes out when you want
it and we use God like that you know
when things I felt that's the only time
that we turned to the Creator yeah so
you know it's pretty much on him right
now mm-hmm
I mean he's he's had the feeling he's
had that kind of Epiphany that that
moment had moment of awakening and now
it's up to him whether he's going to you
know whether he's going to work with
that whether he's going to make an
effort whether he's gonna study whether
he's going to look for the religion of
truth or whether he's just gonna brush
it past and say okay well that moments
past and now I'm going on with my you
know my life as I used to live it before
that's on him man I mean what can you do
that's on him same way for everybody out
there this is on you you know it each
person out there it's on you what you
decide to do with it if you if you want
to pursue it if you want to study if you
want to try try to draw closer to your
Creator then it's on you to make that
effort nobody's going to make it for you
how do you in your experience how do you
see where okay we that's one probably
the main the main aspect because there's
a reminds me of the the verse in the
verbatim
verbatim word of the creator of the
Quran where Allah the Almighty God is
saying that truly and the remembrance of
Allah and God Almighty did the hearts
find rest so I remember when I read that
for the first time and finally I was
feeling myself before Angelia and I
remember I read that that that ayah in
English I'm reading it and I and I got
watery eyed because I felt I connect I
said Wow finally it's not like your your
your it's like you're full of like you
know because many people they make these
these assumptions and they connect weird
things to religion like you're full of
like stay the holy ghost and you jump in
and speak in tongues doing crazy things
and that no you just felt this
contentment that anxiety even the guy
who was asking Tyson Fury the co-host
in in the show he said he said what was
it exactly was I got anxiety PTSD yeah
what's the society talking about I got
the same thing you know to me and that
Nerva that anxiety that wasn't going
away I remember having it but finally
when I started to you know make this
transition and get to know Islam based
on proof and evidence and took an
analytical scientific approach and
everything pointed to this being from
the craters no way could have come from
a human being it wasn't just blind like
yeah I often say in Islam is not blind
faith we just jump in blindly no you do
your homework and you conclude with
reasoning with everything that the
creator gave you that this is indeed the
truth so I confirmed it started living
it and then I'm reading this and I'm
like wow I finally got that contentment
right that like peace it's there so how
do you would you say from your foresight
you have that but then you also have
Muslims you have Muslims we go through
human beings we're human beings you have
days sometimes you're sad right and
someone who says no look I'm praying
five times a day I've committed but I
cannot get I've been clinically
diagnosed as clinical depression I have
mental health issues have you how do we
how do because that's a new thing even
amongst Muslims suicide is in a growing
rapid rate
I mean I it's pretty much you know what
I said from the beginning yeah I mean
Muslims are not immune from this a lot
of Muslims feel that they're on the
right so they're you know the right side
of their creator but at the same time
they want the things of this world we're
human beings we're not we're not Hermits
we're not monks you know shielding
ourselves away from the things of this
world and as a matter of fact in our
religion there's nothing wrong with
enjoying the things of this world but
some people lose their sense of balance
even as Muslims and they start pursuing
the the things of this world as if they
were you know as if it was going to save
them in some way mm-hmm and they find
the same level of disappointment and
dissatisfaction and and it just it just
plays the same tricks on them back to
that you know back to that description
of the things of this world as chattels
of deception you know it deceives you
that you know you think you think that
it's going to be good for you and you
know it's it's just not it's just not
necessarily going to satisfy your needs
mm-hmm I've spoken to a many holistic
doctors also so we would say this main
thing that spiritual connected that
connection with your Creator number one
how much do you think and just your
experiences do you see I you had you
have a lot of people because okay now
you you end up we're in the quickfix
Society you know we see like you know
there's all these commercials out there
if you have this ailment there's this
pill for take this down the other and
someone does go through a little bit of
a depression instead of like amplifying
now your worship your Avada many people
go for the quick fix so they end up
turning towards pain medications they
end up turning towards the drugs and now
you end up compounding a problem there's
a good article written as many who talk
about this this one for instance by
Peter Bergen MD
it's called Matt
datian Madden madness how psychiatric
drugs cause violence suicide and crime
dr. Kelly Brogan she's also someone
who's a very well-known established
psychiatrist she doesn't prescribe any
more drugs anymore she just helps try to
help people through adjustment and
lifestyle through food through natural
means but she through science shows how
all of these come at a cost and this can
alter the biology to chemistry of human
and actually compound the problem yeah I
mean you know as I said it everybody's
looking for the quick fix and it's not
just this I mean everybody's looking for
the quick everything you know they're
looking for fast food they're looking
for you know quick fix from this that or
the other thing so the pill is better
than a lifestyle change for example you
know you have hypertension people would
rather take a pill for that than to
exercise lose weight do the things that
you're supposed to do lifestyle changes
which in the end are more beneficial to
you so that's just a sign of the times
and you find you find some people who
are in it for the you know the long term
so to speak and they're not looking for
the pill they're looking for what what
really gets them over the condition and
then you find other people who would
rather just pop the pill and sit back on
the sofa and flip channels you know you
continue to be a couch potato like I say
that's life you know as the Arabs say
they just kind of hold up their hand
that's the answer right there you know
all the fingers are not the same all
people are not the same they they you
know they choose different solutions to
their problems all I'm saying is that in
with regard to this issue of feeling a
void in your life nothing fills that
void nothing fills that void
except for recognizing your Creator and
submitting to him and then living a
righteous life in obedience to your
Creator and and that's you know that's
just in that category of things that
people want a quick fix for they don't
want that
most people don't want that oh I'm gonna
have to you know commit myself to a
lifetime of Prayer yes you are
you know but you're not gonna get it any
other way yeah that you and you can
always find an example for instance I'll
give one for the people let's say he was
dealing with you said yeah lifestyle
yeah there are people committed to
working out and you know exactly what
happens people know who are in this area
and they have been working out if you
stop working out just for a little bit
boom you start to lose it you don't use
it you lose it it starts to go down you
start losing losing your cardio your
muscle will start to shrink and wane and
that's just for from a few weeks off so
imagine now you stop praying you start
distancing yourself from your Creator
the bother Goes Down and you start
looking for these quick fixes you start
turning more towards the painkillers and
the drugs and then that messes up your
chemistry and you're eating all the
garbage food and all these things not
sleeping right not getting out of nature
doing all the things the lifestyle I
want to understand certain things have
their place in time but you're not at
least addressing these root problems
you're looking like you say for the
quick fix
there's nothing quick about that yeah
I'm not particularly charitable towards
the people who are who are not willing
to embrace their Creator because of
everything I went through and everything
I've seen so many other people go
through you know um and they put they
put themselves their lives their issues
on the line for a greater truth you know
we are the creation we have a creator
and our obligation is to him and they
accept whatever price they might have to
pay to be truthful to their Creator okay
and I've seen so many examples of that I
know anybody can do it anybody can do it
and so if you choose not to I just don't
have much sympathy for you okay it's
your choice do it or not it's up to you
you know it's like I'm a doctor
okay I see patients all the time I'm
seeing patients who are
taking their medication not doing what
they're supposed to do what am I
supposed to do where am I supposed to go
to their home and and give them their
treatment in their home wake them up in
the morning and remind them that they're
supposed to do you know X Y or Z no I
give them the option I tell them the
pathway they can take it or not
they take it they will you know receive
the benefit thereof they choose not to
it's on them mm-hmm it's on them and
it's the same thing here you know I
think I think every human being
instinctively knows that there is a
creator a lot of them deny it they don't
want to believe it they they feel it's
inconvenient to them you know no I don't
have time you know no I I've got these
things I that are important to me or
that I got to do I mean I've heard
people saying no I could no I couldn't
become a Muslim because bacon is too
important to me it's like really
everything else in the world that our
Creator has given you and and your bacon
that's your stumbling block I've heard
other people say you know alcohol was
too important to them this that or the
other thing and it just seems like
piddly little excuses but once again I'm
just in the position of saying look I'm
just telling you it's there for you if
you want it if you don't want it that's
on you you know and I I feel sorry for
you know I feel sorry for people like
this who you know are on the brink it's
like it's like teetering on the edge of
the cliff you can go either way
mm-hmm I don't I don't know which way
he's going to go I hope of course that
he finds salvation but if he doesn't
that's that's a tragedy but that's his
tragedy mm-hmm you know I often when you
mentioned people don't want
not wanting to give up pork alcohol some
of these things out there
and how people would be actually
laughing at at us Muslims for the person
who says maybe he's what's he's in some
where the family event from the his
families as not yet Muslim and they
offer him a drink and then they're like
haha there you know laughing at him
right or or like they're trying to you
know throw the bacon in his face or
they're like laughing all these things
that comes a joke for instance fasting
all your going to starve yourself and
your I can't believe you're doing this
and from from one thing to the next I've
seen now over the years how for instance
when you look at we don't have to get
into the now how many people have saved
their health because they stayed away
from pork and you can go on just google
and see all the health detriments that
happen when you go towards eating pork
just recently they've uncovered and I
think I spoke to you about this who the
World Health Organization talks about
again we've because we live by the
guidance from the Creator we've not only
benefited from these things physically
mentally spiritually but we've been
blessed to be able to protect our lives
our family and protect possibly damaging
other people's life so World Health
Organization alcohol every 10 seconds
somewhat one to count to 10 someone dies
from alcohol mm-hm boom we're protected
from that who's the joke on look at that
and the the studies that they have where
they you can often hear this mantra
about you know a glass of wine a little
bit all this stuff has been bunked they
actually have a new study by The Lancet
talking about no amount of alcohol but
four is good for human consumption
no amount of alcohol and then the list
goes on one last one fasting you there's
a ton of now research talking about the
health benefits of fasting it's a it is
just truly amazing so at one point
people are laughing at you you stuck
with it now everything is turning to
turn up and it's shown that these
actually are things that are benefiting
you spiritually and physically it is
amazing yeah but of course the ultimate
benefit is in the afterlife that's the
ultimate benefit but yeah you know
there's the old saying that he who
laughs
last laughs best and of course
he/she let's be perfect politically
correct but but yeah and the other thing
I get kind of a kick out of is how
people say Oh Islam that's a man's
religion and I just laughs well man's
religion yeah sure you know I mean what
do men like to do they like to drink you
know they they like to fool around they
like pork they like you know they like
the bars they like the girls they like
the gambling and so on and so forth all
of these things that as Muslims we
cannot do stop telling me it's a man's
religion it's not a man's religion it's
God's religion mm-hmm you know it's
God's prescription upon men and women to
live good clean lives yeah you are it's
before we conclude I heard an
interesting story because I was
listening to a one of these motivational
speakers and he was talking about
positive change and how it's very very
difficult to get people to change and he
was quoting a famous psychiatrist
psychologist who was he was well known
established in his field forgot his name
but he said pretty much to get a person
to change some dramatic event has to
happen in their life and I was right
away think it's upon a lot of the tests
that happened in our lives these things
a lot of times you know just force us
you know if you're smart enough that you
wake up and take the good from it but
you you narrated a story of a man who
you would think this is the worst
nightmare may Allah protect us from ever
having to go through something like that
but it was where can you take on where
the father was telling his son about you
know the purpose of life about living a
righteous life a moral life in exedra
etc and then what happened from there
yeah I mean the whole thing about
something dramatic has to happen to
change your direction that's like the
old saying that there are no atheists in
a foxhole
you know once the bullets are flying the
bombs are dropping and so on and so
forth everybody turns to God and
you know just as an aside my father was
a Bombardier navigator in World War two
I remember him talking about a mission
he went on where half of the people who
went on that mission did not come home
okay and now my father was atheist most
of his life he did accept Islam towards
the end but I remember during his period
of atheism when he was in abject denial
of God we once asked him you know well
when you were in those situations in
World War two didn't you ever pray and
he said oh no of course not you know
because I mean he was in his atheist
time just an abject denial of God oh no
of course not of course not and we kind
of pushed and I said well okay we'd say
something like oh god get us through
this something like that but that's all
that's all well there it is right there
Oh God get us through it you know I mean
there are no atheists in foxholes and so
for a lot of people it takes that
dramatic event to wake them up what
you're talking about was just this man I
met who was telling me this story about
how when he was growing up his
grandfather used to tell him about Islam
until he got to a certain point where
his grandfather said okay alhamdulillah
I've done my duty you know God is not
going to ask me whether you became
Muslim or not okay
because I'm not in control of that God
is just going to ask me or Allah is
going to ask me did I teach you what I
know and I've done that so you know my
job is over so this man as he grew up he
was watching his father knowing what he
knows now about Islam he was watching
his father and his father was not
practicing his father was a nominal
Muslim Muslim in name only
sometimes prayed sometimes didn't pray
and like this you know and and could not
be brought to the full practice of Islam
and then just to keep the short story
short he was involved in a horrific acts
don't and in this case it was an
elevator who's fixing an elevator and
the elevator got dropped on him not one
time but three times you know he was
under the elevator and some people got
on it and and dropped it down on him but
you know because of his body being there
the elevator couldn't go all the way
down so the people thought well what's
wrong with this they raised it up I
tried to get it to go down again you
know and of course his body is still
getting there and each time they raised
it up when went down they crushed him
further until somebody pointed out hey
there's you know there's somebody down
there and he was describing how when he
went to the hospital to see his father
his father was barely breathing because
of the fractures of you know his ribs
his father was his he's Caucasian like
me but he was completely black because
he had total body bruising okay and
apparently the the bones were crushed
throughout his body on one side of his
face the eye was out on his cheek
because not because the I had popped out
but because the bones had been so
crushed
you know Wow and they kept him overnight
in the hospital just expecting he would
die when he was still a rot alive the
next morning they told him okay well you
know he's still alive you got to take
him to a you know a hospital that can
deal with this and I said we don't even
know where to start I mean we we don't
even know where to start and so this man
was telling me how he took his father to
the hospital
piece by piece they started putting him
together it took a year after one full
year of of multiple repeat surgeries and
Rehab
and he was able to leave the hospital
mmm alive with just metal and plastic
and implants everywhere holding him
together basically and that's what it
took he you know after that he went back
to or not went back to I don't know if
he ever did fully practice Islam but
after that he started practicing Islam
he's praying five times a day
he started now he's like turned his life
around he was basically he should have
noticed it was not easy for him because
he couldn't read Arabic easily so now
apparently he's so committed you know
he's he's on disability he's at home and
so on but he's so committed that you
know he holds the Quran and reads as
he's praying takes him on up about an
hour for each prayer just because of his
disability and everything anything else
but that's that's his level of
commitment and the kind of shocking part
of this is that his wife you know this
this man was just telling me that his
wife you know was the same as he was
when he you know before he had this this
change his wife is sometimes prays
sometimes Justin sometimes practices
sometimes doesn't and he you know he now
has this rehabilitated Muslim and he's
trying to get his wife to be more
serious about it
my wife just said oh we don't need
another elevator but you know yeah for
for many people that's what it takes
that's you know that's the awakening and
the sad thing is that for many people
they they die before you know they have
that awakening mm-hmm a good place to
start for someone who wants to know more
they have realized that okay life is not
what it's cracked out to be I'm looking
at this Tyson Fury and I'll probably
never make it to the fame and fortune
like that I have a little bit I'm gonna
deal with it I'll maybe try to make some
more there's no
there's no as we say is the money itself
is not evil it's what you do with it and
you don't worship it but you use it as a
means to do good things with it take
care of your family charity and all
these other great things that you can do
with it but at the end of the day that's
not gonna be my number one goal my
number one goal is gonna be to commit to
my Creator but now there is all these
religions out there it's confusing
everyone's making the claim all this
stuff when you really narrow it down you
have two absolute religions that come
down to it you went through all that and
your books is Christianity Islam it
comes down you narrow it down and
where's a good place from all your books
where someone can can go ahead I heard
that you can also download it for free
online please let us know for the person
that now the genuine they're sincere and
they want they want to learn more well
just just go to my website level truth
com or you can go to dr. Lawrence Brown
spelled with you doctor dr. Lawrence
Brown calm and you'll find my works the
books to start with or probably miss got
it and then got it they're free
downloads from the website if you want
to pay for them you can get them from
Amazon you can also get the hardcover
copies shipped to you free from Islam
unveiled dot-org not calm org Islam
unveiled org they send free copies of my
books and other books all over the world
it does take a couple months to get to
you but if you want a hard copy that's
one way of getting it so those options
are there as I said level truth calm dr.
Lawrence Brown dr. hunt calm and yeah
now all I got last advice someone tuning
in in what would you give him there at
that crossroads in life and that you got
their attention what advice would you
give them you've been through a lot
you've been through this journey you
have to be sincere and you have to be
committed you have to know that this is
what's best for you and and you have to
stay the course and you do have to
understand that there are these two
you know these two elements out there
one to guide one to misguide there is a
course of evil out there you can call it
the Satan you can just call it evil
whatever you want to that is you know is
a power to misguide you and you have to
actively work at staying away from it
while at the same time commit yourself
to submitting to the Creator
so beyond then beyond that it's a matter
of praying you know asking your Creator
to open up the you know the path for you
to put you on the path to the religion
of truth and to protect you thereupon
and then you have to do your part you
have to do the research you have to you
know you have to learn about it and then
you have to follow you have to submit
you know thank you so much for being
with us dr. Brown my pleasure
and I bless yous up like I said I'll
make one and let's leave with that
homework alright
you haven't been led here for no purpose
truly everything happens for a reason
and that's the homework to earnestly ask
the creator notice we didn't say a human
being a saint the dead man nothing like
weird a satirical you know you can't
like figure it out and something is way
out there it's something that goes with
your nature I'm gonna ask the one who
created me created creation to the
ultimate reality of things the most
loving the most merciful the most kind
ask the Creator alone for that guidance
and start to do their homework start to
invest the time and for those who have
already submitted themselves to the
crater the Muslims who live submission
to the will of the creator Islam you've
testified you do it every day a shadow
and la la la la la shadow any muhammadan
abduhu wa rasuluh make that the fuel in
your life that gets you through all
these trials and tribulations invest in
it put time into getting to know it
because then your conviction in it will
increase your certainty will increase
your love for your creator will only
increase because what you focus on where
that focus goes the energy flows and
make it flow into this tune in every
week here to the deen show subscribe
again if you haven't hit the
notification bells you get the show
delivered every
to you we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you
Salaam alaikum